Westworld Season 3 Episode 3 is called “The
Absence of Field”. This refers to a poem
by Mark Strand, about a person who exists
in the absence of something else . Cause in
this episode, the real Charlotte Hale is dead,
but a host Charlotte pretends to be her – she
exists in Charlotte’s absence, she fills
in the gap that Charlotte left behind.
The episode starts with a flashback to the
real human Charlotte during the Westworld
massacre – shortly before we see her in
Season 2. Charlotte is terrified, thinks she’s
gonna die, so she records a message for her
son Nathan – [by talking in to the face
of a host so it’s stored in memory]. Later,
in Season 2, Dolores killed Charlotte, and
impersonated her in a Charlotte body. Then,
Dolores left Westworld in the Charlotte body,
and brought with her five host brains, or
“pearls”. Out in the real world, she recreated
Bernard from her memories . And she created
this new Charlotte host. This scene actually
happens before the rest of Season 3 – cause
Dolores has Bernard’s pearl, so this is
before she lets Bernard loose and he becomes
a fugitive . It’s interesting that Bernard’s
pearl is coloured red. Previously, all five
of Dolores’ pearls looked black. Maybe the
colour changed when Dolores recreated Bernard
– his personality now seems to include aspects
of the human Arnold. When the humans James
Delos and Ford were made into hosts, they
also had red pearls – so the red might indicate
Bernard’s human side.
Dolores talks with this new host Charlotte,
who acts almost like a newborn child. She’s
confused at first , but then she remembers
who she is . So – who is she? Presumably,
new Charlotte has one of these five brains
in her head – someone who Dolores took from
Westworld to the real world. Dolores says
she trusts this person , and they know each
other – they embrace, like how Dolores and
Teddy once embraced. Teddy always was Dolores’
closest ally. So maybe Dolores put his mind
in this Charlotte body. Last season, Dolores
did say that Teddy is “one last soul to
carry to the new world” . But Dolores uploaded
Teddy to the Sublime, the digital paradise
for hosts. She left him behind, and it was
big emotional moment showing the cost of Dolores’
choices . It seemed like an end to Teddy’s
story – so will they really bring him back?
There are other possibilities. The way Charlotte
acts with a gentle innocence is similar to
how Clementine used to act. Clementine was
lobotomised, then turned into a mindless deathbot
– so she probably can’t be this new Charlotte.
But Clementine might be a useful weapon, so
maybe Clem is one of Dolores’ other pearls.
Maybe new Charlotte is Peter Abernathy, Dolores’
host father. His brain got all scrambled cause
it held the “encryption key” to the Forge,
Westworld’s data on human minds. Serac wants
that key , so maybe Peter’s brain will be
important again this season. But Dolores had
an emotional farewell with her father before
ripping out his brain – it felt like an
ending, and he was such a minor character
anyway, so he also probably isn’t Charlotte.
Angela worked with Dolores in Season 2. But
Angela blew herself up in the Cradle, specifically
to destroy all the host backups, so she probably
won’t come back. It could be Hector or Armistice
– they are useful fighters. But Dolores
doesn’t really know them – she’s never
spoken to Hector or Armistice. So they can’t
be this new Charlotte, who Dolores knows and
trusts – but maybe Hector and Armistice
could be in these other pearls.
So of these five pearls, we know one is Bernard.
Another could be Hector or Armistice or Peter
or Clementine. The one inside Charlotte might
be Teddy, but there could be a different twist.
Dolores and new Charlotte are surrounded by
imagery of mirrors and reflection. In their
hotel room, there’s this statue of two identical
figures reflected symmetrically, and this
symmetrical artwork. There’s also a mirror,
and these shadows, there’s copies and reflections
everywhere. Maybe new Charlotte is a copy
of Dolores, and that’s why Dolores trusts
her and knows her – she is her. Dolores
says “No one knows you like I do. No one
knows me like you” – that line itself
is like a mirror image. New Charlotte says
“Why can't I be myself? Like you?” – which
could mean Charlotte’s real self is Dolores
. Dolores’ goal is the birth of a new host
species , to grow like the cells in the opening
theme – maybe, as a host, she won’t reproduce
sexually, but by self-replication, by copying
herself. Maybe all of these pearls she took
from Westworld are blank, and she’s just
copying herself onto them. Like the Smiths
in The Matrix, Dolores could fill the world
with herself. But new Charlotte is not identical
to Dolores – she’s younger and more vulnerable,
she’s more like a daughter than a copy,
and Dolores cares for her like a mother. Their
embrace is like Maeve with her daughter. Motherhood
is a big theme this episode – with Charlotte
and Nathan, Caleb and his mother. And all
these relationships are difficult. Cause kids
aren’t just copies of their parents, they
have their own influences and conflicts that
make them grow into something new. So there
are a million possibilities, but it seems
likely that new Charlotte is a copy of Dolores.
And thematically, their relationship explores
motherhood, and growth, and change. That’s
how life survives – by never staying the
same.
Dolores gets new Charlotte to impersonate
the old human Charlotte. Because old Charlotte
worked at Delos, the company that owns the
Westworld parks, and Dolores wants Delos to
keep making hosts – maybe she just needs
the pearls to copy herself onto. Charlotte
gets a giant robot – the Delos website calls
this The Mech, it’s apparently a cutting-edge
dystopian riot control machine. Apparently,
Delos made three hundred of them , and Charlotte
says she’s sure she “can find some use
for them” , so no doubt she’ll send these
things on a rampage for the robot revolution.
Charlotte learns that she’s lost control
of the Delos company – cause a heap of stock
was bought by companies controlled by Serac
.
A Delos woman called Irene says that Serac
is like a black hole, because he’s invisible
– there’s no information about him anywhere
. But, like a black hole, you can detect him
by his influence . Serac is the wealthiest
man in the world , but all his wealth his
hidden, so he can be detected in the world’s
missing money, in economic negative space
– like that poem again, the absence of field
. Irene says that Delos once sold Serac a
sample of data from the Forge – all the
human minds recorded in the Westworld park.
And that’s why Serac bought out Delos, he
wants that data , which makes sense, because
Serac runs Rehoboam, which uses surveillance
data to predict and control people.
New Charlotte goes to the home of the old
human Charlotte – she intrudes into the
life of the dead person she’s impersonating.
And she finds old Charlotte’s ex, Jake,
who startles Charlotte so she immediately
starts fucking him out of pure confusion.
Jake calls Charlotte “Charlie”. And Charlie
is the name of Arnold’s dead son. There
was a crazy theory years ago that Charlie
is somehow a younger Charlotte. So this line
might be the showrunners’ way of teasing
the audience over this theory – Jonathan
Nolan says they “love to fuck with Reddit”
.
We meet old Charlotte’s son Nathan, which
forces us to see old Charlotte differently.
In past seasons, she was always a ruthless
corporate headkicker with zero regard for
human or host life . So it wasn’t terribly
sad when Dolores killed her. But now we see
that poor Nathan has lost his mother, so we’re
forced to see some tragedy in old Charlotte’s
death. Also, these arrow shapes look a lot
like these shapes on Rehoboam in the intro,
which is.. curious.
New Charlotte mentions that elephants are
now extinct. The only elephants left are these
host elephants in The Raj. It’s like how
humans might go extinct and be replaced by
hosts – just like how human Charlotte was
replaced by host Charlotte.
We learn that old Charlotte was a pretty shitty
mom to Nathan – Nathan says that Charlotte
doesn’t love him . So new Charlotte does
her best to be a mother to this human child,
just like Dolores tries to be a mother to
new Charlotte. Once again, the most real and
sincere relationships in this series are not
with the humans, they’re with the hosts.
At Delos, Charlotte learns that someone at
Westworld stole some host brains, including
Maeve’s. We saw last episode that Maeve’s
brain was taken – apparently so that Serac
could put Maeve in his simulation, along with
a bunch of other brains. So there’s a mole
at Westworld, working for Serac, stealing
host brains . We later learn that old human
Charlotte was working for Serac, but she’s
not the only mole. Because old Charlotte was
likely dead before Maeve’s brain was stolen.
And Serac says he has other people under his
control , so it sounds like there’s another
mole at Westworld, who stole Maeve’s brain.
There aren’t many options on who this could
be – cause the only surviving humans who
we know at Westworld are Felix, Sylvester,
David Benioff and D. B. Weiss – so unless
one them works for Serac, the mole must be
a new character – or perhaps some even more
ridiculous twist.
New Charlotte starts cutting herself, she’s
freaking out, feeling like the old human Charlotte
is inside her, trying to cut her way out . New
Charlotte might have some Forge data on old
Charlotte, like a copy of old Charlotte inside
her so she knows how to act like her. But
behaving and thinking like someone is pretty
close to being that person. The whole idea
of hosts in this story is that machines pretending
to be people become those people – like,
Maeve didn’t really have a daughter, she’s
a robot – but she played the role of a mother,
and that made that identity true. So now this
new Charlotte, playing the role of old Charlotte,
is becoming like her – she’s playing her
role “a little too well” . The cutting
is interesting, because when the human James
Delos was made into a host, he also cut himself.
The idea is that copied human minds struggle
to survive in host bodies . Also, the cuts
are shaped a bit like these circular images
from Rehoboam, which is… interesting.
Charlotte comes to Dolores for support, and
all the dialogue and imagery fits with the
idea of new Charlotte being a copy of Dolores
. Dolores says that to take back control of
Delos, she’ll need to visit “an old friend”
. Dolores has called William an “old friend”
before , [and William twice calls Dolores
“old friend” ]. And William is super rich
and has lots of Delos stock. So maybe Dolores
and Charlotte will get William’s help to
take back Delos from Serac. Last season, there
was a flash-forward to a “far future”
host version of William in a loop . But in
the present timeline, we saw William alive
in Westworld .
New Charlotte sees the recording of old human
Charlotte – it’s a heartfelt message to
her son Nathan. Akecheta once said that you
live “as long as the last person who remembers
you” . Old Charlotte is remembered, and
in some sense she lives on in new Charlotte.
New Charlotte is moved by this message, it
seems to inspire her to be a mother to Nathan.
She finds Nathan with a creepy child predator
– so Charlotte murders him on the spot.
Then Charlotte takes the man’s dog, and
gives it to Nathan – a dog is not as cool
as an elephant – but it’s a start. Charlotte
makes a real connection with Nathan, and she
achieves it through murder – this is a fierce
kind of motherhood. She says this murder helps
her to remember who she is – a “predator”
. So is she referring to her identity as Dolores,
or her identity as old Charlotte, or as both?
Maybe she’s finding a new identity from
a combination of influences. Cause that’s
how people grow, right? New Charlotte started
like a child, vulnerable and innocent. Then
she went through a teenage stage, rebelling
against her mother Dolores . Now, she moves
towards adulthood, with new confidence and
certainty in her identity.
New Charlotte tells Nathan “You are my sunshine”
, cause she learned from old Charlotte’s
message that she used to sing that song to
Nathan . And this unlocks a mystery. Cause
throughout the episode, Charlotte gets these
weird voice messages that play buzzing noises.
She uses the You Are My Sunshine melody as
a password to unlock her mysterious contact
– Serac. Cause the mole in Delos feeding
data to Serac was old human Charlotte . This
connects way back to Seasons 1 and 2, when
Charlotte tried to send data outta the park.
Turns out she was doing that for Serac – cause
he wants Westworld’s data . Serac needs
the encryption key to unlock Westworld’s
data, and he says the key is in Dolores’
head . Though last we saw, the key was in
Peter Abernathy’s head.
It’s interesting that Serac appears here
as a hologram – he’s a phantom menace
like Palpatine. The only other time we see
him is in this weird garden with Maeve, which
for all we know could’ve been in another
simulation. Maybe the real Serac is dead,
and what we see is a digital manifestation
of the computer Rehoboam. Like how Ford died
then lived on inside his creation , in Season
2. Dolores says that Rehoboam’s data forms
a digital “mirror world” – maybe that
world is where Serac exists.
So Charlotte is in a crazy situation. She’s
totally new to this world, yet she’s gotta
pretend to be Serac’s mole, and pretend
to be loyal to Delos, and pretend to be a
mother to Nathan, and pretend to be a human,
while starting a robot revolution with Dolores,
all at the same time. Dolores expects her
to be obedient to her, but maybe Charlotte
will choose her own path, maybe she’ll help
Serac, or embrace her identity as Nathan’s
mother. Charlotte may have started as a copy
of Dolores or someone, but kids aren’t just
DNA – they grow and change depending on
experiences and environment. In Season 1,
Stubbs said that children “all rebel eventually”
.
Meanwhile, Caleb helps Dolores after she was
shot in Episode 1. Dolores is a stranger to
Caleb, but he’s determined to save her . We
know that, in the past, Caleb’s friend Francis
bled out in his arms – Caleb couldn’t
save his friend. So maybe he wants to redeem
and make peace with his past by saving Dolores.
He gets her to an ambulance, and the medical
computer finds that Dolores’ blood and hormones
are weird, because she’s a robot. And since
the computer gets confused, the medics do
nothing. Which shows how over-reliant this
society is on technology. Caleb steps in and
does the obvious thing, treating the wound
– he must have medical training from the
army. And instead of relying on a machine
to tell him what to do, Caleb thinks for himself
.
The ambulance is pulled over by police, but
Caleb sees on Rico, the crime app, that these
“cops have been bought”, they’re criminals,
who’ll hurt Dolores – maybe they’re
sent by Serac. Though it does seem like a
pretty bad design flaw that the app warns
its own potential victims. So Caleb stands
against the cops, and defiantly faces a gun
pointed at him, just like he did in Episode
1.
Shit gets real, and Dolores kills the cops.
She’s hurt from her wounds, but as a robot
she’s still strong enough to drag corpses
around with one hand while wearing heels – and
Caleb is suitably impressed . Dolores steals
a cop car – unlocking it by facial recognition
– and Dolores thanks Caleb for helping her,
telling him he’s “a good man” . Last
season, Dolores brutalised humans, saying
they’re evil and have no free will – but
now she acknowledges that Caleb made a choice
to help her . Dolores realises that not all
humans are bad, and they don’t deserve to
be wiped out.
After the shooting, Caleb’s a wanted man
[like Bernard], so he tells his mum he’ll
be away for a while. His mum doesn’t recognise
him, and says she wants her son back . This
might just be cause of her mental health cognitive
issues, or it could mean that Caleb actually
secret died in the army and was replaced with
a robot – he does make a weird comment that
he’s a “dead man” , Or it might just
mean that Caleb has been changed by his traumatic
experiences and is no longer the boy his mother
knew – or maybe it’s all of the above,
this is fucken Westworld after all.
Caleb is captured by people from Rico – they
want info on Dolores – maybe they’re working
for Serac. So they torture Caleb, using the
digital drug device everyone has. Apparently
it’s called a “drip”, and since Caleb
was in the military, his is extra powerful
. The Rico guys use it pump up Caleb’s heart
rate, risking heart attack. So in this dystopian
future, technology can control people just
like hosts are controlled – this is just
like when Bernard was digitally tortured last
season. It’s easy to imagine how militaries
and governments and corporations could misuse
this kind of control. Caleb heroically refuses
to hand over Dolores – not that he could
hand her over – cause he knows nothing about
her. For the third time in three episodes,
he’s defiant when a gun is pointed at him
– showrunner Lisa Joy said that Caleb doesn’t
value his own life very much , he has suicidal
impulses, so he’s not just being brave here,
he’s being self-destructive.
Caleb has flashbacks of his past, and this
shot looks like Caleb and Francis in weird
masks – you can tell it’s them, cause
Caleb’s wearing the same outfit as this
shot. The eye design on the mask is interesting
– Rehoboam is a sort of an all seeing eye.
Maybe Caleb and Francis weren’t just soldiers,
but were activists or terrorists fighting
against Incite and Rehoboam – we have seen
protests against Incite in trailers.
Caleb’s robot friend comes to help Caleb
– maybe he’s programmed to save people
when they’re in danger. But the criminals
push faithful innocent George to his death,
Fs in the chat. But then another robot friend
comes to save Caleb – Dolores.
Dolores found out that Caleb was in danger
from Martin – or rather from the host that
Dolores replaced Martin with in Episode 1.
We don’t know whose mind is inside this
host – it could be someone like Hector or
Armistice, or maybe it’s another copy of
Dolores. Martin found out Caleb was in danger
from surveillance footage . It’s weird that
Martin can so easily spy on Caleb, and yet
Serac, who runs the whole system, is apparently
unable to find Dolores, or to notice that
Charlotte has been replaced by a robot – maybe
Serac actually does knows this stuff, and
is manipulating everyone.
There’s been a lotta talk this season about
data technology controlling people, but so
far it’s been abstract and vague. So Dolores
explains specifically how the Incite corporation
affects people like Caleb. She shows a transcript
of a conversation Caleb had when he was a
kid, when his mother left him at a diner and
she was institutionalised. It was a terrible,
traumatic, private memory, and so it enrages
Caleb to see it laid out in a corporation’s
surveillance database . At the diner, kid
Caleb puked milkshake on himself, and this
shot looks just like William’s memory of
his wife’s suicide. This is a cornerstone
memory, a moment that defines Caleb’s life
– and so along with data on calls, jobs,
purchases, and relationships , Incite can
exploit this information to control Caleb
.
Dolores takes Caleb to a pier, and says that
Incite’s data predicts that in ten years
or so Caleb will kill himself – that his
mental health, military history, and every
other moment, leads here to his death . That
prediction is why Caleb didn’t get that
job before, because companies use Incite’s
data to make hiring decisions, and they don’t
won’t to hire someone who’ll just die.
These kinds of algorithms are already used
to hire people in the real world , and have
been criticised for bias . Caleb’s profile
says “Marriage not recommended. Children
not approved”, “Restrict social interaction”,
so it looks like companies and platforms have
manipulated Caleb to hold him back, because
of the data they have on him. This takes away
Caleb’s free will. Cause he might’ve not
killed himself, but because this prediction
prevents him from progressing, he’s more
likely to do it. It’s a self-fulfilling
prophecy . It’s like in Season 2, when James
Delos predicts that his son Logan will relapse
into drugs. Because of James’ prediction,
and his lack of faith in his son, Logan does
relapse, and ends up dead . Data doesn’t
just describe the present, it shapes the future,
and takes away human choice . So Dolores gives
Caleb a choice – he can run away to a new
life , or he can join her “revolution”
against the system. She wants to unplug Rehoboam
and Incite, and “show this world for what
it really is” . Caleb chooses to join her,
because she’s the first real thing to happen
to him , the irony being that Dolores is a
host. Which Caleb doesn’t seem to have figured
out yet – how will he react when he learns
that Dolores is a robot? Season 3 is a grand
conflict between freedom and control, and
humanity’s liberator is a machine.
Serac says he wants to save the world by using
data to control humanity. But he comes up
against individuals like Dolores who he can’t
predict. These same ideas are explored in
Isaac Asimov’s Foundation, a classic sci-fi
series which was at one time developed for
TV by Westworld showrunner Jonathan Nolan.
Asimov also wrote hundreds of short stories,
including the collection I, Robot. Asimov
was a huge influence not only on Westworld,
but on how we all think about robots – he
invented the word robotics. If you’ve never
read Asimov, maybe start with The Last Question,
which he said is his favourite of his stories.
You can any of these audiobooks for free right
now by signing up for a trial with Audible.
Members get an audiobook each month, and if
you cancel, you keep the audiobooks. You can
listen while you social distance and stay
at home [spooning]. Sign up at audible.com/asx.
Thanks for watching – please like and subscribe.
We’re holding livestreams right after each
episode of Westworld Season 3, at about 10:30pm
Eastern Time Sundays. Patreon supporters can
watch livestreams after broadcast. Thanks
to Patrons Haley, Paddy Dallimore, Rickard
Holgersson, Greg Knauss, Vikas Bhardwaj, The
idkyeet, and vfuwo1jb9d. Cheers.